الجواب هو أن بوتين قد خسر بالفعل
الحرب لديه مشكلة حقيقية
[موسيقى]
الجواب هو أن بوتين خسر
الحرب بالفعل يواجه بوتين مشكلة حقيقية في
كيفية انتقاله من هنا ، وماذا يفعل ،
وبالتالي فإن فكرة أنه سيكون
هناك ما سيستخدمه يمكنه إنهاء
الحرب غدًا يمكنه فقط أن يقول إنني خرجت ،
لكن الاتفاق الذي تم التوصل إليه في النهاية
يعتمد على بوتين وما يقرر فعله في نهاية المطاف [بوتين
] الموسيقى التي يخسرها في الحرب]. سيقرر أنه
ليس من مصلحة روسيا
اقتصاديًا أو سياسيًا أو خلاف ذلك
مواصلة هذه الحرب ،
لكني لا أستطيع أن أتوقع بالضبط كيف يحدث ذلك ، وآمل
أن ترى أن أوكرانيا تحقق
تقدمًا كبيرًا في هجومها
وأنها تولد في تسوية تفاوضية
في مكان ما على طول الخط ،
شكرًا لك
لا يمكن لأي شخص
الانضمام إلى الناتو أثناء الحرب
تدور الحرب حيث يتم مهاجمة دولة من دول الناتو
لأننا
في حرب أجنبية
نشكر لك ذلك.